did we talk about crumble crumble on
here crumble crumble yeah crumble my
crumble my dick up and crumble with no I
don't know oh you know what's a good one
sorry what there's a Racing League
called imza I've been trying to figure
that one out
imsa I NSA I
am like I'm so like I'm so something
that could work I'm
uh we'll figure it out yeah someone in
the comments yeah yeah but someone
messaged me over the weekend they're
like are you in the imza I said oh no n
nice try nice try dude I blocked that
kid nice try
man I reported his account for abuse
yeah yeah he's just going around asking
like really inappropriate questions yeah
are you are you in
imza anyway sorry so crumble cookies can
you look this up on Twitter oh these are
the ones that are made of hot diarrhea
and yeah actually that kind of looks
like it is oh these are the ones that
are smeared with rabbit
[__] so crumble cookies is like a big
ass franchise now yeah you can buy one
of these things and the franchises make
like you can open them up and bum
[__] nowhere and they make like
millions of dollars how much does it
cost to open one of
these uh I don't know but hold on before
we look that up can you scroll down so
this is the craziest [__] about this
these look so sexual okay look at this
look at this page right here can you
zoom in on the calorie info right there
there what does that say 180 with an
asterisk right calorie counts are per
serving serving sizes very based on
product and a lot of them
are are like four and a half servings
per cookie per cookie so there's a
there's a like a pumpkin cream cookie or
something like that or a lemon one with
icing on it that's over 1,000 calories
it's more than a Big Mac like meal I'm
pretty
sure hanai in 10 880 calories in one
that like that was like my whole Taco
Bell order that's what I'm saying that's
crazy and the [__] crazy thing is
they're like this big if you have D if
you have type
two if you have type two sound off in
the comments could you like end it with
one of
these damn that's dark but I actually
want to know the answer to that I mean
that's that's what's the sugar how how
much 40 grams of sugar go to their go to
their like just normal menu
I want to find this lemon one what is 40
grams of sugar like 40 cubes yeah I also
want to know like let's get some
perspective on that as
well how much is in a Coke hold on let
me just look that
up well that one's you know it depends
if you do it in your ass off your
friend's dick if you put it in your nose
you know just it depends where you do it
you're going to lose it depends what
it's cut with yeah you know whose
stomach you're doing it off of are they
clean you know 40 gram of sugar is about
9 to 10 10
teaspoons wow that's not that much I
mean think about a teaspoon yeah let's
think about eating 10 of those in a row
two three it's feeling excessive now
yeah yeah no no here's what we're
forgetting it's 10 tp9 gram of sugar
okay so it's a can of Coke but maybe
it's what the issue is is um it's a can
of Coke and then you take a block of
butter and then you just go like
this yeah
exactly
exactly now imagine yeah taking a stick
of butter how much butter is in
this oh I guess it wouldn't say what how
much fat 40 gram of fat okay there's 92
gram of fat in a stick of butter so this
is half a stick of butter over yeah half
a stick of butter and then imagine like
dunking that in sugar and then pouring
like four more teaspoons of sugar on top
and then and then microwaving that and
pouring [__] on
it eing it I knew I do I was waiting for
it I'm like
please yeah that one that's what that is
right there man yeah yeah it's called
pumpkin brownie for a reason no but
isn't this isn't this just the most
[__] up like
deceitful a deceptive marketing oh and
this is but the fact that they list the
calories with just an asterisk and then
you can't get to the actual like that
makes it seem like there's 140 calories
in that whole cookie oh this is
dystopian as [__] man and then you know
it's going to be great when they start
doing ads with skinny people eating this
stuff
yeah show people who weigh 70 PBS being
like I love my crumbl cookies in the
morning yeah smiling next to it this one
this one has OIC icing on
it we introduce the uh OIC buttermilk
pancakes because you know we thought
it'd be a fun partnership and it's a
cute way to counteract what's going on I
just listening to some podcasts here
talking about like the new version of
OIC I don't know what the drugs is
actually called but OIC 2 no yeah
literally it's four times as appetite
suppressing as OIC that's good man yeah
[__] crazy that's [__] yeah that's
great yeah hell
yeah uh I'm trying to figure out how to
get that OIC R OIC Type R the allnew OIC
will keep you never eating for days max
just shown a bunch of OIC Pro Max do you
think OIC would suppress my appetite to
eat just a big bag of diarrhea in the
middle of the
day bag bag like a shopping bag like a
Trader Joe's bag worth of
diarrhea
worth
worth dude just showing up to a picnic I
brought strawberries what did you bring
opening up a
cooler I brought the bag of diarrhea
oh
Luke nice what even is that man that's
chocolate milk but damn is that that
looks for a second I was like dude that
looks like bagged chicken
meat jamming a straw into a chicken
breast all right we got to stop we got
to stop this sh we have to stop this I'm
laughing you know when people fast
forward and they're like haha okay guys
and they're just trying to find the part
yeah yeah very funny di hot back eating
poop in the Sun
clicking 10 seconds what is going on
guys [__] how long do they [__] talk
about this [__] baking in the Austin
humidity imagine you poop through a
funnel come on man they get to 55
minutes imagine dipping a stick of
butter and sugar okay Fally and then
pouring hot diarrhea oh God damn it [__]
[__] no that that cookie is
really like just taking a Coke can
cutting off the top putting half a stick
of diarrhea in
there
damn that got me I didn't even see that
coming diarrhea a STI of diar just
opening the fridge it's all Frozen
turns that's going to be food supply in
2200 dude yeah dude jenz that's you guys
have to look forward to after the Earth
[__] Heats over there's no food left
and you have to just slogs and tur yeah
just cricet shakes and turd
sandwiches there's a 19-year-old
listening to this
like should we eat the creamed turds
tonight or the creamed
box the cream oh man there was there was
a section of the class last night where
they were talking about like how long
breast milkers no it was how long breast
milk lasts in different forms like like
when it's freshh it can last like 5
hours on the counter or whatever but in
theid it lasts like 3 to 5 days and then
you ra your hand you're like what if I
make it a popsicle yeah yeah no no
that's literally it said Frozen but I
should have been like what happens if
how long does frozen [__] last
yeah it's like what what do you mean
sometimes like to free my sh yeah yeah I
can't make breast milk so if I freeze my
[__] how long does that last in the how
long does it stay fresh I'm just
wondering all the dudes are like I'm not
going to feed it
to yeah actually a question you guys are
asking all these now if I diarrhe it in
my hand and a little slips out is that
okay before I put it in the mold okay
got it then when I throw it in the
fridge about how long till it's hard
cool my [__] has been completely liquid
for about 3 months do I have ass cancer
or what's the deal it's all these women
with their with their left breast
out